what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday
august the 4th from the heart of
[__] new jersey
the joint is brought to you by
draftkings
the official sports betting partner of
the ufc
this weekend friday saturday ufc
265 the main card is my main man
derek smell my balls my balls are hot
louis against my man mr gain draftkings
has a kick-ass offer for you if you
haven't joined draftkings yet
now is the time to do it you ready for
this one 100 to one odds if a punch
lands during the main fight a single
[__] punch are you kidding me or what
you bet a dollar on any main event
fighter and if a punch lands during the
fight
you'll cash 100 and free credits
if you know anything about mma then you
got to put your money
where your mouth is either way this
weekend
you're getting paid a [__] yardstick
don't worry if mma isn't for you
draftkings has great odds on the tokyo
games
draftkings are safe secure and reliable
you withdraw your money at your [__]
convenience
don't miss out on all the action at ufc
265 this weekend
draftkings is here to put it together
for you download the draftkings
sportsbook app
not the fantasy app the sportsbook app
today
right now use promo code joey j-o-e-y
when you sign up to turn on one dollar
into a hundred dollars in free credits
when you bet
on any main event fighter to win and a
punch is landed in either fight
that's code joey to turn one dollar into
a hundred dollars and free credits
only at draftkings sportsbook and here's
the fine print you knew it was coming
you got to be 21 older new jersey
indiana or pennsylvania only
new customers only get this deal so
right now
listen it's a free yardstick what are
you [__] waiting for you put a dollar
down
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
slash sportsbook for details if you got
a gamer problem
call 1-800 gambler or in indiana call
1-809
with it but if you don't have a [__]
problem
and you could keep it together now
download the draftking sportsbook app
and let's win some [__] cash ufc 260
[__] five
the joint is also brought to you by one
of my all-time favorite c
b d lion when it comes to cbd
the lion has you [__] covered vapor
pens
bath balls cream they got hemp flower
they got the capsules they got [__]
tape
listen if you need cbd in your life a
cbd lion will make it happen
start with the [__] gummies with
melatonin in it they will rock your
[__] world
if you get too high and inedible what do
you do you sit there and complain no
you eat a little melatonin gummy with
cbd in it
and it calms you down that's some free
advice here from your uncle joey now do
me a favor
go to cbdlion.com read the third party
lab results and get back to me
this ain't some [__] guy in a liquor
store [__] around
cbd line has done the research and they
will let you know what's good for you
what ailment you have what to take how
much to take what the rub
listen from the roll-on to the cream to
the back ball
cbd lion has you covered go to
cbdlion.com
order some cbd pressing code joey
join and get 20 off your order delivered
straight to your house
it's time to start the [__] joint
[__] it's a beautiful wednesday
august 4th let's do this [__] [__]
welcome to uncle joey's joint
[Music]
my
what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday the 4th
of august thank you very much for all
the [__] emails i got about monday's
podcast about comedy
it was time i busted out and let you
guys know what the [__] rules were
a lot of people out there [__] around
with comics and i don't like that at all
whether you're my friend or not
as a comic people have no idea how hard
we [__] work
to have some guy that didn't have the
balls to do what we did
tell us and [__] with us that's not
gonna happen ever again
i got a lot of emails from a lot of
young comics asking me to comedy
coaching and [__] that
i can't i can't [__] judge your
material that's not what i do
i've never i've never jumped in on
somebody and said hey the material look
at my [__] material
it sucked i i did it on presents and i
was a good storyteller and i had good
presence but
as a writer i'm not bill burr or mullany
of those guys but
i could just give you rules like i do on
him that's just [__] fine
today we have a guest you know on
wednesdays i always have a zoom
but we'll do that later you know i'll
talk to you about what's going on and
whatnot
i'm feeling good my teeth feel better uh
the stitches are
i spit out my last stitch last night i
went to watch jimmy's son play
basketball
on the way out of the park i felt
something in my mouth i'm like what the
[__] is that
i took it out it was a [__] stitch
with old blood on it whatever [__] it
i just spit it out of my mouth the birds
eating it right now some [__]
that's what usually happens i threw a
piece of gum out the [__] window
about a week ago i come back an hour
later bird was [__] eating the gum
bouncing around the nicotine gum
he didn't know that that [__]
nicotine oh [__] a bird up
but anyway today we talk about comedy
again i have a
nice comedian one of my uh tight friends
george perez that you guys love he's got
a great [__] podcast
i'm gonna do it in a couple weeks but we
covered a lot of comedy [__] on here
today you know and uh
i got to tell you a story real quick
when i was doing comedy about
three years 95
that put me at about three and a half
years january of 95.
i was doing comedy and i was doing great
i was in colorado
i was in boulder and i was doing
i had about 20 minutes 22 minutes you
know and i went out
every night when i was in boulder the
comedy scene
was fair to midland i mean uh
monday night she had like some [__]
room at a outback
it was it's not the same outback you
guys think this is an outback bar that
was
australian also but and it was like a
recording room
that sat like 20 people that was my
monday night tuesday night was the
comedy works
jimmy beta had a room on two million on
tuesday night
if you didn't get the comedy works open
mic wednesday night was club 52
in commerce city thursday night was el
torito
in [__] englewood or wherever the
[__] it is uh
i forget what part of denver it is where
they do
littleton i think it's out there by john
elway fuckingville
and then friday and saturday i would do
guest spots at either the comedy club or
i would deliver chinese food or whatever
the [__] i was doing on fridays and
saturdays because
you know a lot of people you can't call
the same club for guest spots every week
but tues wednesday nights at club 52
it was buck wild they gave you i think
it was 25
cash and a steak a [__]
delicious steak so we you would go
earlier
and i would leave there and go to the
italian restaurant i told you guys about
in the church
with the elvis impersonator i was a big
fat elvis impersonator
he looked nothing like elvis but he was
an impersonator in vegas they cashed him
out
and uh he did like 20 years at some i
don't know what hotel
and he opened up a little italian
restaurant he would do elvis with the
belt
and then he'd give out food it was a
[__] nightmare but i did it
it was part of the [__] game but what
i'm going back to this
one that i was a club this is just to
prove to you [__] i wasn't
taking
[__] when i was an open miker i'm at
this club
and i'm eating my [__] steak and uh
i forget who th i know who the headliner
was i still see his face
i can't just remember his name you know
and i get there and he was headlining we
were both eating
i was doing like 15 minutes there was no
some other comics there eating
and we're watching the comedy show they
had to be 20 people in the audience
maybe
two of these dudes were sitting there on
a table like this one
and they were flicking beer caps at the
comedians you could see
like that it wasn't lit the room there
was just a light on the comic on stage
and you could see him ducking from the
[__] bottle caps i'm like
these [__] they look kind of
tough and [__] so i was like you know
what i'm not gonna say nothing to him
i'm just gonna say something when i get
on stage i don't know maybe four or five
comics went up
they kept flicking the beer caps out of
them the whole [__] deal
i go up there i get to grab the mic and
i go listen
the first beer cap i see i'm not [__]
with you [__] i didn't even
stop
the words didn't even come out of my
mouth and a beer cap
flew through my [__] head i mean
these guys were not playing
i go [__] you [__] you bunch of
[__] what i wanted to do is i
wasn't gonna go to them
i wanted them to come to me and one of
the guys actually got up and he goes
you're a tough guy i'll [__] beat the
[__] i
go come up here and say that before he
could hit the stairs
it was a portable microphone and [__]
that was on the thing
i [__] picked up the stand and i just
belted him on the [__] head with the
microphone
the microphone broke the batteries went
off everywhere and [__] he was holding
on to his head
his buddy got up and ran out i just got
off the stage
picked up my steak and got in the car
like the cops are coming
and i took off about a year later two
years later
i'm at harvey's comedy club in portland
and the headline is there
and he comes up to me goes you're
opening up for me tonight i go yeah he
goes
just don't hit nobody with the mic on
the head and i was like fine [__] it
nobody will get hit
and that was my classic story i didn't
take [__] as a [__] stand-up comic
as an open micro you have to lay the
[__] rules down and i'll tell you
what after i hit that kid in the head
with the microphone
nobody [__] me in denver again the
word got the [__] out
so don't worry about nothing don't let
nobody [__] with you if you're a comic
i told you guys on monday that nobody
could shut you down
only yourself nobody
not rogan not chappelle not [__] well
mitchy sure is dead i don't feel so good
myself
nobody could [__] shut you down so
keep doing what you're doing
and watch the podcast and i'll drop
comedy tips on you
from time to time i'm not the best
[__] comic in the world
but i tell you what i did do i didn't
make it work for me
i don't know how i don't know what the
[__] happened but
eventually i'll make it work for you
[__] anyway
today's guest is my main man mr george
perez
i've known george since [__] a long
time we did uh
the comedy latino thing for showtime
together
uh we fed each other we had each other's
back
i miss him with all my heart you know uh
but
we're still tight and that's all that
matters we were a great team on the road
i used to take him on the road with me
and i miss him so now enjoy george perez
i'll be back after the [__] show cup
suckers
oh [__] what's up brother what's
happening my brother how are you today
on a beautiful [__] wednesday morning
no i'm good i'm good man i'm good i like
that shirt
thank you brother that shirt says
[__] rodney
that's a good album yeah that's a good
[__] album you got some good albums
there on the wall
[__] wanted that are alive the pride
behind you i don't even want to say it
because people get pissed
you got my [__] album back there
that's a nightmare i like it
i remember when you did it oh i i do too
i don't want to remember
it was [__] horrible i bombed the
first show
i had a change to set around it was a
[__] i'm not good with specials george
i'm just not a good special comic i
check on the pressure
i'm only good when i'm live [__] that
[__] yeah i feel you
what's up buddy nothing much man we
podcasted last night
chilled you know it's weird not having
my dog around man
i'm sorry about your dog it's a [__]
night man but give it a breathe and then
go get another one
and now i'm not gonna get no more that's
it you're done i'm done
yeah my daughter wants me to get a dog
here i gotta wait for the cats to die
and then i'll get a [__] dog i got
the yard and everything but
you got to be careful with dogs here
because they got the ticks from the
[__]
deer and [__] and next thing you know
you're dizzy
and that's [__] it how's it work
how's california treating you
california's good man the strip club's
good but uh
you know the comedy store they want like
a full background check now
[__] they're checking the bar
code on everything now
so what's the barcode it's on the on the
on the [__] vaccination
yeah it's on the vaccination cause i'm
looking at that card that card looks
bogus
yeah but the codes are put in the
computer and your phone number and your
email and your birthday come up
okay so and you haven't gotten
vaccinated yet
hell no but i got the card okay yeah
that's the way it is [__] it
don't let a lot of people know they'll
give you a [__] felony that's the
last thing can you imagine
going to [__] and having a felony
because you use the [__] covet card
and they give you like three years
because they want to make an example and
[__]
and you're in jail with covert
oh [__] dog that [__] is running through
prison
oh it ain't that [__] was running
through the prisons that's why they
inoculated those [__] first
but you know what they were sharing if
you had kovid
you were supposed to give it to the
whole dorm so people ca
people had cobra were getting released
early
damn what a [__] scam
[__] co and cough in his face
hey dawg i've seen videos where fools
are like i got covered drinking that
eventually
eat off his ball get it get it you get
to go home
no [__] how many people did they release
in california
i think they released like 30 000 god
damn that's a lot of criminals walking
around doug
yeah but it was like you know drug
charges nothing major
you know can you imagine george being
locked up with covert now
i would have [__] i don't know how
[__] up it is to be locked up now
i've stayed out of that [__] hole for
30 years i can't imagine we're going to
prison this night now no smoking
yeah [__] just it's not you know you
did it
we did it already we got it out of the
[__] way
you know i'm happy i got it out of the
way it's never going to happen again
i can never get [__] locked up again
dog that was
that's [__] up when they take away
your freedom that is [__] up man
people have no idea how [__] up it is
when a man wakes you up and kicks your
bed
you gotta sit up for count you remember
that [__] you gotta sit down and wait
for a [__] to walk by all quiet
[__] that eight counts of [__] day
they come in and move your sheet at
night to make sure it's you that you
have an escape because i was at a camp
yeah i ended up at a camp you know i
went through the [__]
diag i was thinking about diagnostic the
other day doug i had to go for a blood
test
and i'm like dog i'm gonna faint in this
[__] thing they had us like in a
little pod
i'm gonna faint and they're gonna [__]
me in the ass these [__] i was
petrified
and dog usually i tell a lady when she's
taking out blood to
be a little careful because i faint i
didn't say nothing
no way and i sat down it was one of
those [__] school chairs
the desk i put my little [__] [__]
arm out and [__] i looked the other way
i was trying to make believe i was hard
and [__] and i'm like yeah i'm gonna do
this and [__] she shot me george
took blood out and uncle joey didn't
faint i walked in that [__] thing
with a stroll to me and [__] like what
[__] say something
later on i went to my room i'm like oh
i'm straight i put my arm down like let
me see what happened i took
a piece of cotton off there was a piece
of cotton with a little dot of blood i
fainted in my [__] cell duck
i went down like a bad habit i woke up
20 minutes later with a lump on my head
and [__]
[__] walking around with ice
it's a [__] nightmare when you try to
be hard and you ain't thug it's a
[__] nightmare
my diagnostics was different uh
we were at war with like the prison was
at war with each other
so they made us sit in these [__]
cages
like in like because no one was allowed
to wait in the doctor's office because
fools were fighting right there
and we were just waiting in those
[__] cages man and it's
bakersfield [__] freezing at six in
the morning dog
you're just sitting there waiting and
[__]
honestly i was worried because i was
[__] a lot of chicks back then and
they're like yo dawg you find out if you
got aids today
like i was worried they were like yo
they do every test and i was just like
damn yeah thinking of magic johnson and
everything at that time i was like damn
dawg i'm going to own the dodgers eh
[Laughter]
it's crazy how when i got locked up it
was 87.
88 88 is when i got locked up i'm coming
on the anniversary now august 15th of 88
and uh
when i got locked up
hiv was huge
oh yeah so the prisons had to build an
hiv wing
every jail i was at was under
construction but when i got
to camp george west and golden they
already had an age unit george
you had to see this [__] thing stated
state-of-the-art appliances they didn't
want these [__] in the kitchen
or nothing
no no they didn't know they had their
own setup
state-of-the-art the [__] they had a
tv in their
big screen tv already in 88 i remember
going in there and watching the dodgers
so we would hang out at the age unit
my headquarters was the age unit that's
why i took book
that's why i brought my food that's why
i did everything was the hiv unit they
only housed
five people and they only had three
people in the rooms
wow so they were like nobody talks to us
because they treat us like [__] with
lepers
so when i got there the one black dude
was tremendous and he's like come on
over say hello whenever you want
i went over there one time i didn't
leave
i didn't leave they're like dog you got
hiv i don't give a [__] i'd rather be in
here with you guys i would wake up and
shoot over there
those guys had everything they would
have huge parties
on football sundays because they were
all into football
food tacos you know they didn't [__]
around those jailhouse tacos that are
[__] good
people would bring in popeye's fried
chicken the brothers would always bring
in popeyes fried chicken on sundays
we'd watch football and then marry with
children and you know you watch
america's most wanted in jail
that's the favorite show that and cops
they love all that [__]
they will sit there and clap for the
criminals and [__] and [__]
tell their stories what a blast it is
people have no idea sometimes you have a
good time in jail i had a good time dawg
i i kind of miss it man like sometimes
i'll get like
little messages here and there for
people i was locked up with on my
instagram or facebook and
and then you know like they can only
trigger memories that we've gone through
on there and they were just like yo dawg
we were locked up we were in dorm 307
i used to stay right there by the shower
where we used to hide the thing by the
tile and i was like
oh [__] and i do miss it i just
like you said dog is just a man telling
you what to do
[__] me up now that [__] me up now i
enjoyed it listen
i i knew i wasn't gonna escape i knew i
was gonna leave
you know because i had a friend that
told me he goes [__] that
i got a hurts rent a car that you could
be a manager training at in like el
salvador or some [__] they wanted me to
go to like
a south american cut and i thought about
it i thought about [__] running and
not doing the time but you know what
then you have that [__] on the one day
when you do get your life together
you got to go to the hospital with your
kid they run a background check and
there you are
and now you got to do that 30 [__]
years still
plus the escape plus all that [__] so i
was like you know what i'm just gonna go
in there
do my time and make the best of my
[__] time and that's exactly what i
did i got into running
i got into book you know i got into
booking [__] football games i became
my jailhouse attorney i help people with
their appeals and [__]
i took the test you know i made the best
of it so
but i knew i never wanted to go back
george yeah now
joey were you your healthiest when you
were in like
i could imagine you dog like were you
healthy in 88
yes i got in shape yeah
i knew that you know in the back of my
mind i'm like i'm gonna beat this thing
but in my head i ain't that stupid
because they told me there's
no way you're not gonna do something
they caught you with a machine gun
that's a a lot of [__] could have
happened with that machine gun so we're
gonna
give you something so yeah i was hoping
that maybe you know
god would you know you ever hear the
story of saint francis of a [__] he got
[__]
he got [__] uh you know
they set him up he was innocent and he
went to court
and the window was open and the note
blew in that said he was innocent of
some [__]
you know i was like maybe this will
happen for me the story of saint francis
of his [__]
but in reality i was getting ready dawg
i was hitting the bag
i was riding my bike i was swimming i
was running
i was you know you never know so i was
just getting ready
they had to wait so hard back in your
day they took weights out when i got
locked up you guys had weights
we had weights we had a punching bag
they had a little laundry room with
weights in there they had a card game
that's where the brothers would play
cards in the laundry room
there was just a little weight lift in
there and i would eat breakfast and
shoot to the gym
you had to sign up so i had like a 9 30
window
you had a half hour at the gym so it was
okay
man i hung out with a [__] and then i
became friends with a [__] that was
[__] dynamite i saw him
what happened a [__] a [__] he was
[__] filthy rich okay filthy rich
he was younger than me if i was 25
he was 23. all right
he had seven cars and seven girlfriends
each of them had one of his cars and all
of them had one of his kids
wow he made sure you get a car you got
to suck my dick
and i had my kid he had seven eight nine
kids
and he had his main woman that had two
kids or three kids
then the rest of them were all side
pieces yeah
so all the side pieces would come see
him on saturday
and his main woman would come on sunday
and they would bring
tons of food especially nutter butters
yeah those are the thing right there
baby so we would eat nutter butters on
sunday night watching america's most
wanted what
in the hiv unit what we get green chili
uh burritos and [__] with mashed
potatoes
it was on dog it was really a lot of
[__] and i know people going to watch
this guy how the [__] was prison fun it
was fun
for me it was fun i didn't get high in
there nah i mean either
i refuse to get high now now i didn't do
coke
i didn't smoke weed i did acid because
they couldn't test for acid
so acid was running rampant in that
[__]
me and the [__] librarian the black
and another white dude used to get
[__] up and sit down the park bench
and
the guard would see us then he pissed us
the next day if a guard sees you out
late
[__] around they piss you yeah the
next day so my number will come up i go
in and piss all happy and [__]
you ain't gonna get me because they said
they had to require a special test for
acid
who the [__] knows man nah dawg i
i remember where i was at like you see
when i'm locked up everything's banned
there's no
cigarettes you don't smoke either no
arnold schwarzenegger took that [__] out
he even took sugar [__] out you could
only buy like candy bar you couldn't buy
that
from the you got to get it from a
package so
i remember one time we were bored joey
you know when you're bored
it's you and your boys and i was living
in a dorm at this time because my points
dropped
i was on good behavior and they're like
all right full you're not gonna live in
a cell no more you can go hang out with
other inmates
and this is the first and only time dog
you know those plastic spoons the sports
[__] he put a little liquid in
there and he was just like look dog we
call this a caldito i'm like what's a
caldito he's like it's heroine and
something else
all you gotta do is snort it and i
guarantee you
your troubles are gonna be gone for
today now you know what they [__]
give me half
dog i don't i'll never feel like that
again man it was like ten blunts to the
face
and one hit a death star the [__]
blackout brownie
i remember just kicking a dog and then
like that was when i told myself
[__] could have happened you today fool
don't ever do this [__] again
were you [__] up i was [__] they
wouldn't even let me go eat
they're like yo dog we're gonna bring
food back to you stay in this bed
because i've never had kind of that [__]
in my system
it was i did some i did some brown tar
in there yeah
i did some brown towel with the mexicans
they [__] took a dropper and put it
in my nose
i'm not gonna lie to you i didn't get
high at all i didn't feel nothing it was
a waste of [__] heroin
but i was so bored one day they were
like dog we got some [__]
black tar and you don't have to shoot it
you could just drop it in your nose i
said give me a [__] drop
then there was this crazy white dude
from philadelphia his name was john
clark
i'll never forget this dude he had like
a reputation you know those dudes when
they land in jail like they've been he
did
like 20 years yeah and i caught him the
last [__] six months of his sentence
and he hated everybody he had a big
[__] picture hitler on his chest
this dude hated blacks whites
spanish he didn't give a [__] but me and
him hit it off
so his girlfriend would come in on
sundays make out with him
and spit a [__] balloon in his mouth
with speed in it
and [__] sunday i would never see him
but i'd see him monday afternoon he'd
ask me you want a line
and i'd say [__] yeah because they
couldn't test you for crank either
so i'd do a line of speed with him and
i'd be losing my mind and monday nights
we played basketball dawg
you should have seen me i was like
robbie [__] benson and one-on-one
when they got them
all [__] up i don't know if you ever
seen one on one that's an old school
basketball movie
77 with uh bob benson whatever the
little
cute little white dude he went to
college and they [__] him up and [__]
but he got [__] up during a game of
practice they gave him like reefer
and he's putting the ball behind his
back that was me on the speed that night
i'm putting the ball behind my back i
was [__] up
you go up in the air and i'm like holy
[__] i'm not gonna come down
like that's how [__] up and [__]
high would be and then i just stopped
i'm like i'm not doing no more speed
no more basketball i'm not doing that
[__] no more jumping up and i don't
think i'm gonna come down
yeah that's [__] crazy how old were
you joey
when you were locked up 25
i got a sentence when i was 25 nice and
young
right there to get you out in the system
it saved you though right it saved you
yes i have no regrets yeah
i have no regrets it made me at least
realized
that the life i was living you know when
you go to prison and you come out
nam how many times did you get locked up
twice or once
i've been to prison once but like i've
been in that county
fighting cases like five to six times
yeah like um the first time i fought a
case was a gun charge
and then the i remember the d.a was just
like
look man just they dropped it on me it
was like 93
misdemeanor in california and they were
like just
[__] let it go and then yeah
the county sucks you guys don't have the
county out there in colorado right
yeah we had counties jefferson county
boulder county jail
[__] like that yeah it was cool they had
it down over there
but it's crazy how when when you got
locked up when you came out you knew you
weren't going back in nah i didn't know
that yet dawg
i did not know yet because it was weird
i don't know if you heard the story but
you're the only you're the first person
to get me on stage
after i got out of prison because like i
was kind of like i don't even know if i
want to do comedy [__]
you know what i mean and like
nah man i never wanted to go [__]
sorry my my mind just flipped to every
[__] dude i was locked up with
yeah it happens i get caught up
sometimes too man
yeah because they were like yo homie we
don't want you back here
represent us out there george you're
[__] funny you're a homie
show the world that we're funny i can
just remember those faces dog
it was a shame for me to be in there
they were ashamed of me
like what the [__] wrong with you yeah
you watch your showtime special in
prison yeah
that's [__] crazy because that came
out after you got locked up right
dog i was in bakersfield and you guys
were doing a show in bakersfield
really [__] yeah we turned the tv on
because you know
and in roscoe they give you like a day
room tv
you can see it through the corner that
little that little uh
window they have on your cell that
little door thing that was like a [__]
straight
yeah and i just remember looking and
[__] and then
that's when it set in dawg like
in my head i was really going like hey
dawg this is how
childish i was at the time in my head i
was going like you know what dog i think
these fools are gonna come bail me out
for one day
i'm gonna go tell jokes and then they'll
probably let me back in
[__] what a dumb ass bro it happens
listen i felt shitty when i got out
but now i hold that prison sentence like
dear to my heart it's like a medal
because without without that [__]
medal i would have never ended up here
it wasn't i
listen i knew prison was in the cards
when you're throwing up spaghetti
against the wall it's gonna stick and i
was doing a crime every [__] day
every day i did a felony something a
misdemeanor i did something i cried i
jaywalked
i did something when you do something
every day eventually so i knew
i knew when i was like 23 and i would
have police contact
i'd go someday this is gonna get more
serious
yeah and i didn't know if i was gonna be
43 or 53. so i'm happy
it happened when i was 23. yeah it
happened when i was 24. i got pinched
for the kidnapping at 24
and i did the time a year later the
youngest kidnapper i know dog
you see people that kidnap they're older
and they get younger people you're a
younger person that kidnapped the older
person that's crazy
dog it was a [__] bad day
what were you thinking honestly like you
threw a [__] in the trunk
george when you're doing a crime you're
not [__] thinking
yeah you know i've done a thousand
crimes
and as you're doing it you know what the
[__] you're doing okay you know what
you're doing
you know that it's bad but you pray for
the best
[__] yeah with that day with me
it's funny because i went to the dentist
last week and they gave me gas
i asked for the gas and the doctor asked
me what's the last time you got gas
they put like a little pig nose on me
with two little things in the in your
nose
and it didn't really [__] work that
good but the last time i did gas
was the dad kidnapped ken bella oh
[__] november 17 november 18th 1987
i went to the dentist at nine in the
morning i still got the [__]
the silver in the cavity what's
still [__] good the cap is still all
those people that said silver sucks [__]
you
that [__] is in there that tooth
is never hurt again they've never had to
do a root canal on it nothing
so i got gas that morning and then that
afternoon
i can't blame the gas you know i could
have probably got off
but i was like i ain't gonna say nothing
because i did it
you know what good i did it if i get
another excuse and i get let out i'm
gonna do it again
i'm gonna keep doing this after they
arrested me i got to be honest with you
i was happy i was happy that it came to
an end
like my karma was going to change
so if they would give me probation and
90 day work release i would have learned
my lesson
i just knew i never wanted to be in
those [__] in that [__] cell again
i just knew it but i knew that
that was going to happen to me i'm not
going to sit here and tell you that i
didn't know i was going to go to prison
i knew i was going to go i quit high
school i didn't have a diploma once you
ain't got a diploma
you're on the fast track to prison yeah
you ain't got a ged
yeah you ain't got a high school diploma
you're on the fast track
all you need is a knuckle tattoo all you
need is like a tattoo on your neck or
one on your knuckles and you're official
yeah
that's it you're official they're going
to throw you in jail eventually that
comes with the [__] program you know
so when i got when they told me i was
going to pray
yeah i was a little upset but not really
george i knew it was coming
as long as you know it's coming and you
know the day is gonna you know
i was okay with it and i'm proud
that i did my time i'm proud that i went
up in front of that judge
and didn't leave i didn't talk to people
was saying leave leave the country
come back in 20 years you know what man
i wanted my life to move forward i
wanted you know
i wanted it to go somewhere i always
wanted my life
to go somewhere i did 30 years of comedy
but i really it took me 30 years to
become a man george
hey i feel you dog comedy got me to this
spot today where i am
all that comedy and dealing with people
you know when you
when you jump into comedy you got to
work hard
you know i was talking about pete rose
this morning how i patterned my comedy
career
after charlie hustle right up you know
you got to hustle that word in the 70s
was huge
they even wrote a song about it due to
hustle it was huge
that song that word was huge in the 70s
and early 80s it's not used anymore
hustling hustling hustling is a [__]
thing that you put in your soul
and you'll never miss a meal yeah you'll
never miss a meal
who is it immigrants immigrants
immigrants hustle dog you gotta hustle
because if you don't hustle so with
comedy anything i did
i added that hustle but that hustle was
built in the 70s
this country was huge that word was huge
in the 70s
you don't hear it no more nah now it's
getting hustled
yeah now nobody hustles no more and it's
a very easy concept to add to your life
yeah it means that you ain't stopping
and when
you know you have to always like i
remember talking to don marrero one day
we're talking about basketball
when you play basketball and you're
serious about basketball
there's no sitting on the couch there's
no [__] sitting around because
you got to think mike is the guy that
i'm going up against he's the other
guard that i'm trying to start
what is he doing is he [__]
practicing
maybe maybe not that means i gotta go
practice
and that's the hustle the hustle never
[__] stops
you know it's not the big things that
you do it's the little things
so i'm just trying to bring hustling
back i want these [__]
young kids to get hustled back in their
vocabulary
hey dog remember when i remember when i
first got out of prison
i [__] had five rooms a week
i had the sunset room on tuesday i had
casa latina
on wednesday i had roscoe's on [__]
thursday i was doing a ghetto hotel
montebello you don't dan hit me up
he's coming dan hit me up he's coming to
new york
oh [__] yeah danny bird hit me up
he's coming to new york i hit him back
and he was like dog i didn't think
you're gonna hit me back i said how many
[__] sandwiches you give me to take
home
on a wednesday [__] night when
somebody gives me a sandwich
i never forget about you those [__]
triple decker sandwiches he would give
me for the way home
you give me a little weed by the time i
hit the five i had to eat one of those
[__] sandwiches
how big was i and then i'd stop at
[__] uh king taco
oh i was addicted to mexican rooms dog
i loved mexican rooms because i knew on
the way back
i was going to king taco and i'd
definitely have forty dollars
either you would give me 40 felipe would
give me 40.
and when san juan would give me 40.
everybody gave you 40. fly would give
you 40.
so you do two spots a night willy
barcena will give you 50.
how people have no idea
how much how grateful i am to all those
mexican rooms
they have no idea that's how i cut my
teeth
yeah i remember you telling me this [__]
dog dog i [__] loved that
monday night room you had that started
at 11 with the [__] chicken wings and
[__] and the chick
the pretty chick that worked i never
talked i never said two words to her
i was always embarrassed to talk to her
she was beautiful
tuesday's casa latina i remember still
[__] oh my god i remember going in the
backyard there
they had a little door in the back and
edwin san juan had a [__]
glass pipe in his arm and he took the
pipe out of this [__] jacket it was
this [__] big the pipe
oh my god you've had that in your arm
all [__] night
and we would just puff [__] 20
[__] joints rodrigo
you me edwin felipe
fly jeff garcia i mean it was a
[__] what chapel
oh [__] ivan yeah oh yeah
ivan hey speaking of these mexican rooms
like
a lot of people you know uh a lot of
mexican
fans they know the underground [__] like
hey was there a room
at a room in denny's and downey that
gabriel iglesias and willie barcena used
to host
it was a dangerous yes they told me it
was cracking
bro tuesday nights it turned into a
denny's
oh you're right it turned into a denny's
it was something else dog i went down
there one tuesday night
like the first time willie booked me
down there and uh where was it
it was in downey downey and it was a
cuban neighborhood
oh down he's got like a little cuban
neighborhood to it
how could you tell because that's where
all the cuban restaurants are in downey
there's a big population of cubans and
downey
two people had rooms in downey willy had
one and another guy had one i forget who
was the other kid who had one
but willie's room the first time i went
down there i went on stage and i did
that [__] with my jaw by doing coke
and dog every time i went down there
some guy gave me a block of coke
i would go down every tuesday whether he
gave me 40 or not i'd go down there for
a guest set
yeah because i knew i was getting a
chunk of [__] coke from that [__]
cuban dude
it was some [__] cuban dude but till
this day
uh your boy gabriel had the
bicycle casino oh
when he first started gabriel glaciers
paid 35 bucks
at the bicycle casino on thursday night
you had to drive back on friday and get
paid
why i don't know it was a [__]
nightmare you had to drive down there on
friday
at three o'clock to get a [__]
paycheck you know with all that traffic
and [__]
gabriel used to book that when i first
got there and your other boy
gilbert had a room in long beach
that had a taco truck outside for 50
cents
a taco and the tacos were world class i
still remember bringing my coke dealer
with me
to that gig because i owe the money he's
like i'm going with you
i'm collecting tonight cocksuck i have
like three gigs 50 a piece
and what's the show what's the room we
used to do in universal
on monday nights john lovitz
the conga room there you go that was
ernie g's
wow wow i remember i went i went there
one the night before i left for the
longest yard and i had not a dime
and ernie gave me 40 bucks greg jeff
garcia gave me like 25 bucks
and i think somebody gave me a half a
pack of cigarettes
so when i left for the longest yard
that's where i got the cash from from
those [__] people
yeah what about wild coyote remember
that for used to make a sign of [__]
voucher and [__]
trying to get tremendous tremendous wild
coyotes
name was oscar oscar yep
now he runs the hotel across the street
from the long beach laugh factory
really yeah the long beach slab factory
right across the street
out there you know me back when i used
to do all coke i'd go outside and hide
smoke cigarettes
and then i seen him
relax nobody could imagine
that's why i'm very grateful to you
felipe even the dude who had the room
in the chinese town what's the chinese
town where they have
all those [__] things that people sit
down remember we used to have a chinese
restaurant that was mobbed up
by the monday night room that you had oh
yeah
yeah there was there's a restaurant the
restaurant they'd be playing cards in
there
i remember i went in there one night the
waiter looked at me is like nah
we don't serve white people it was by
the kfc on hacienda
yup by the kfc and the donut shop
the donut shop was across from it had
some bad ass [__] donuts
that room used to start at 11 o'clock
dog on mondays i still remember driving
back at two like going what the [__] was
that
two in the [__] morning on a monday
we would start at the laugh factory
the comedy store and i'd shoot to you
out there
it was a real [__] spot [__] yeah 50
bucks
50 bucks is 50 bucks back then let me
tell you something i didn't know how
much money i was making until they took
it away from me
what do you mean i was doing all those
rooms
from 1997 the mexicans opened up their
hearts to me
from rudy moreno at the brave bull to
sebastian satina
the brave bull i mean all those dudes
[__] open their hearts to me in 2007
the economy flipped
remember everything washed out 2007 2008
we were doing an acting class behind my
building in hollywood me felipe
silent bob edwin we were all getting
together tuesdays at 11
we'd stay there till one and then we'd
go to the weed store
on sunset and the guy would make edibles
he was a baker
and he would make like [__] apple pie
and all this [__]
so i remember
in 2008 my wife asked me once she goes
where's the money
and i go what money because i was living
off residuals
and a little bit of the road with joe
rogan and she's like you usually have
money during the week because all those
rooms went down
i got locked up you got locked up that's
what it was
all those rooms went down so my income
you know those rooms were making you an
extra
800 a week because i was doing and we
were doing
up north they had a mexican room up
north that they were booking
we had a lot we had a lot of [__]
work
and it shut down so that cash
we missed that cash those 50s and those
forties
groceries hundreds yeah they add up
it's gas in your car it's reefer the
next morning it's you know that that
money had added up
i never knew because i was always doing
coke so i was always broke but once i
quit doing coke those rooms were [__]
paying my bills
i'm like look at all this [__] money
i got dog in those days i would check my
bank account and i would always be at 18
sixteen dollars every once in a while i
had twenty three dollars and i could
take a 20 out and buy a sack of weed
from the [__] wheat store grandma a
weed or something
but i never had over 20 bucks in that
[__] account
once i stopped doing coke those mexican
rooms i had 6 700 in my account i'd be
walking around like what
look at uncle joey with 600 in this
[__] account
all right with the new leather jacket
with a new leather jacket and [__]
but yeah after those rooms went it it
left us out in the [__] cold we
didn't really know how much money we
were making
yeah dog i i remember uh do you remember
the first time we met
it was like an underground room it was
it was peppers
in the city of garden grove off of
harbor and chapman
who used to run that room rick martinez
yes that's the room where he [__]
taped me the week before and people
coming up to me going do you have a dvd
and he goes i got your dvd
what he taped me at his show the week
before without telling me
he was a sneaky dude rick martinez god
bless him though
i don't know where he is he disappeared
he was [__] a new chick every week
with a bmw dug
was that he was getting married really
he really [__] was
and you know what dawg yeah he was a
little overbearing
but he had the gift of hustle yeah
exactly
that dude he had a room one time with
samoans and they threw a knife at darren
carter
diane carter was on stage finale with
the light
and a knife went flying right past him
and it hit the door and darren caught a
look at the [__] thing and he like
melted
they threw a knife at him down that dog
it went right past him and hit the wall
and it stayed in the wall like rambo
and rambo [__] too when he chopped
the [__] vietnamese heads off
dog they just threw it at him listen
when you get a knife thrown at you in a
comedy room
that means don't go back like don't ever
go back there
and i think i went back there and i'm
like what what about the room
that you had when we got there they were
that shot the doorman the night before
and there was a bunch of mexican candles
in front of it and [__] they shot the
guy the night before and we're doing
comedy the next night
yeah what was the name of that oceans
oceans
you're right oceans i was there one
night when noes
noise that's right i was there one night
when
noey's wife just got out of jail
and she came in with the [__] with
the
with the wristband and she's like you
gotta lend me 20 bucks i'm like
lend you 20 bucks i need to buy coke
who's got the coke and she's like i'll
get your coke if you let me to 20 bucks
i just got out of county jail i've been
doing 90 days [__] knew
no he threw him threw me in jail or
something they thought she was
bro that [__] was crazy i still
remember
dawg i still remember being in la jolla
with her
i was the headliner me and marilyn
martinez would call headline
and noy would open up for us so noy
would sleep in the couch
in la jolla and him and that girl would
get [__] up
and i remember one night i will open up
that thing we had a bathroom in the main
bathroom in the main big room i had a
bathroom in there but i think i needed
water
and i opened up the door nori was passed
out and the chick was still playing with
a [__]
with a little paddock i'm like what the
[__] oh my god i didn't think you were
awake
i'm like no no leave the blanket off let
me look at that [__] monkey she was
beating that [__]
dust was coming out of it
the whole thing i'm like what the [__]
but oceans was the room that
i went there one night and the doorman
got shot the night before
and i'm like i'm on stage doing comedy
i was there at a place where a
[__] got shot last night
the families were out there praying for
the body and [__]
[Music]
he didn't get shot on comedy tonight no
like a hip-hop night
right he got shot like the night before
or something like that but you tell
people those stories they won't [__]
believe you
they're like there's no way you were
doing comedy in those rooms we didn't
give a [__]
we didn't give a [__] i got [__] with
a lot at wild coyote
did you yeah because see
a lot of comedians that understand that
i'm an orange county gang member
and i was in [__] montebello nader
you know you noticed not one black fool
lived in that city and mandela
yeah montebello or el monte
it's just mexican even the asians they
get their eyes fixed to look like a
cholo
like yo dawg hey dawg there ain't no
there's no cover than monbello yeah no
there's no coconut montebello dog
and i was there with head remember head
training sure
dawg i was i was doing good on stage but
the fool was like hey homie get off we
want to dance hey everybody knows you're
funny
and i [__] up joey i [__] up i
started [__]
going at that full boom boom boom
because you know that was the cold
if someone heckles you eat them up out
of [__] nowhere dog a spooner hits
the stage you know those big drinks they
used to have over there
amber was the amber was the waitress
and they [__] threw the spoon around
me that [__] hit the big sandal behind
me
a dog i tried to go out there and head
was like hey homie
i i gotta escort you out the kitchen
george they're gonna get you
and a [__] head took me out through
the kitchen i ain't gonna lie dog
i i could have thrown like like you
remember those dope feed punches you
could throw back then you're like i just
gotta hit this one once keep the car
running
keep the [__] car running but head
was like nah dawg
i work here officer is gonna get tripped
that was like the craziest incident i
got over there but like remember when
they jumped flying tommy chung
i kind of remember that
i got jumped in uh san bernardino
no way that's why i got jumped it's that
over there
they tried to rob me dog in san
bernardino then another night i went up
there with felipe
and they would they set up they set us
up they were going to put us in a car
and robbers
oh me and felipe
yeah they don't [__] around up there nah
you know i've been robbed once
by a gun and i remember i remember my my
tight ass homie evans
he was just like look dog whenever
someone pulls out a gun on you
do you want to keep that 200 bucks or do
you want to have another chance
to get that money back and live he's
like someone pulls out a gun i'm done
now if you ain't got none i mean i
remember they pulled our heat on me and
took my cash once
it's kind of [__] like i don't know
doc i felt like i got
you know i'm not trying to diss no one
but it was like my my only way of rape
i feel like i got raped i was under no
control there's a [__] strap to my
head
i only had 30 bucks they were mad at me
[Music]
i was like i already paid everybody dog
there's nothing wrong
let me tell you something plenty of
times i got broke into a house
and there was only a gram instead of an
ounce i was pissed off as a [__]
though you're gonna
you commit the felony to get no [__]
dough you put a gun to somebody that's a
felony
and they show up with 30 bucks you're
like god damn it
a minimum i needed 300. minimum was 300
but you know what man what comes around
goes around how many moves how many
fools did we mug
yeah straight up straight so what comes
around goes around man so as long as you
understand that concept
you know i used to muck those dudes at
hudson county park when i was a kid
make believe i was a [__] stalker or
some [__] and [__]
you know and it you got it coming to you
what are you gonna [__] do but nobody
one time a guy pulled the gun in harlem
when i was copping
but they didn't rob us what happened
what year was it
81 yeah cause there's no
cameras out no there was no camera we
grew up in
no there was no cameras you could have
got robbed before just had a gun in the
[__] trash bag you would have been
like hey hey hey
and i had if i had two friends that went
over to the city got a blow job one
night
and they got out of the car and the
chick was blowing them in the park
and next thing you know was a setup
three guys came with guns and robbed
them i mean took their sneakers
took their belts took everything so they
couldn't chase them and [__]
so i made a mental note i was like 16
when they told me that story they're
like dog we just got mugged in the city
we went for a [__]
the chick was sucking our dick and they
pulled guns on us and [__]
and i'm like [__] it i ain't never
getting myself in that position
but i went over that city a thousand
times to cop
and nobody ever pulled the [__] gun
on me knock on [__] wood you know so
now i don't cop no more the other day i
was i hang out with a newer cop
okay i was talking to him we were
watching uh the kids play and i asked
him
i go they sell drugs and he was telling
me how the streets are buck wild in
newark dog
somewhere paterson that's where
everybody goes
to get their drugs on the street pills
you get anything down there
i couldn't even imagine going down there
now
i couldn't even imagine rap my you know
how many [__] things i used to walk
into all those weed circles in harlem
and cocaine circles that everybody's
slinging on the street and i would duck
i would i used to live for those things
i love those
walking into those things i couldn't
even imagine
copping drugs off the street now i
didn't even know where to start
hey so is is harlem like the capital of
new york as far as like
is that the easiest place to get it like
say you go uptown
say you go brooklyn it's like people set
tripping on you
dog i don't know anymore but i remember
20 years ago maybe 1997
i went to port authority and i couldn't
get a hold of my friends so i went to
harlem looking for drugs
after giuliani came to new york he
cleaned that [__] out so i don't even
know
like i haven't been to harlem yet i've
been here 11 months
i've been to the city but i haven't been
to harlem i've been to brooklyn i've
been to queens
but i didn't see no drug dealers out on
the streets but he was telling me
that in jersey and newark they got
[__]
drug people on the street no they're
passaic
patterson they got them out there
selling heroin the whole [__] thing
yeah in newark they have three dollar
bags of heroin
yeah that's right that they saw hirono
on the street
i wouldn't even know where the [__] to
start george can you believe that
i mean neither i wouldn't you can we get
wheat online now
there's a there's a site that i tell
people here in jersey where they get
weed from
in california that's tremendous you have
to send them cash
and then they send you the weed three
days later it's [__] tremendous
my brother orders from them all the
[__] time
they're popping up here like left them
right now from california
yeah no you can't grow wheat on jersey
right
i think so i think it's legalized i
don't know the
it's hard to grow though because of the
weather right
they grow in a house [__] it huh
yeah they're growing houses so i
wouldn't even
i don't even know where to start copping
now if i needed to cop
like if i need to cop weed i would go to
north berg i got a kid up there that
sells pretty decent wheat he gets it
from cali
supposedly you know what i'm saying he
gave me a bag one day
but it didn't look that good i gave it
to a friend of mine but yeah i don't
i don't even know what the [__] to start
with copping anymore doug
the hardest weed i had to find was your
laughing gas dog
well there was only one store that has
it yeah and like i had the [__] i had
a full waiting out there like you know
how they wait in line for sneakers
i told that for you i need a [__] bag
dog and i
that hey that [__] [__] me up homie i
don't know what they put in it
you know when you smoke a new stream it
was a new strain to me i don't know what
that is but
it it was some good [__] man are you
sold out of that
there's a little bit left and then more
comes out on the tent
are you gonna have it in jersey i'm
gonna have him send some to me
absolutely i already smoked what he sent
me
that [__] was deadly dog i gave a bag to
mike i kept the bag
that [__] was deadly all right you know
what man i i hate to tap myself on the
back pat myself on the back
but that's good [__] reefer man
hey i was i i smoked it and uh
[__] carlito's way was on
the part where [__] it i i suck at but
remember when he go
he's doing the court appeal and he's
like johanna it only took
five years not 30 too life like you
thought
oh my god broomfield
headed out of the [__] park with that
movie dog huh
sean penn headed out of the [__] park
with that movie
he was tremendous as the [__]
attorney he was tremendous
you know what i saw that in the movie
theater i didn't like it as much as i
like it now
yeah now i really like that movie that
was the beginning of the movie when he's
in
with his appeal and then they get them
out and they go to a puerto rican bar
and they're dancing with the girl from
miami vice
and the two girls say what the [__] you
want to hang out with each other and
they're both drunk at the bar
yeah that's a great [__] movie i like
the better now than what i did when i
went to see it
why you don't think you understand it
like you understand it now yeah
it was completely different when i saw
it the first i'm like what the [__] is
this this is like a redone
this is like a remix have you seen the
prequel to carlito's way
i won't watch him horrible horrible with
louis guzman and puff daddy and [__] and
the puerto rican kid
[__] terrible terrible and i was in
the ground floor on that movie they
reached out to me i'm like nah
nah that movie looks a little [__]
fishy
but i love you george perez i'm [__]
happy to see you this is just
this wasn't even like a [__] podcast
this is just great to see you man
catching up with you man i miss you dawg
it's been three months since i saw you
is it different now it's different dog
it's like
yo man i i've never felt like a dinosaur
like i feel old to these fools and but
but i'm still not i know i'm not
it's just like like yo dawg i want to go
to hollywood to try to hang out at
three clubs and it was like going to a
prison yard that like nobody was there
no more just the guards
just the workers it was [__] weird
dog
weird no jeff at the store that [__]
hurt that was weird
that was weird that was weird i hear the
store
isn't the same i hate to say this
as it was i'm hearing little things you
know what man
i'm going to be as honest i can with you
george i don't feel old
i am old thank you and i have to be
honest with myself
that i didn't want to have white hair on
stage
and tell [__] jokes you know what i'm
saying like i look [__] like who's
this dirty old man on stage so
if i do go back all those [__] jokes
are going to change
you know what i'm saying but i already
think like i don't think i'm uh
done i just think i did what i had to do
i feel you dog you know sometimes in
life you do what you got to do and you
move the [__] on
you know but i feel like uh i feel like
an old man you know
being around young kid like it would
feel creepy for me i remember when i was
21 the 25 year old dude would come to a
bar
and i tell that dude to go mend a
sweater you're too old to be hitting on
21 year olds do you know what i'm saying
and that's how i feel now i have to be
honest with myself
and go the opposite listen you're too
[__] old joey
you know if i get back on stage i gotta
wear a suit
yeah i got to put on a [__] suit
yeah you know i got to do it right
there's no way i can go back up there
with a leather jacket like this
this is my favorite stand-up shirt i
bought like 13 of these
i only wear three of them i still got
them in wrappers and [__]
this is as comfortable as can be this
this is my comedy shirt
the [__] you wore in the showtime
special though yeah yeah
with the boots and [__] i love all that
stuff on stage but
now if i get on stage i got this white
hair
it's a different story i'm just trying
to be honest with myself you know it's
it's
i don't want people to go look at
[__] joey dying his hair and going up
there telling [__] jokes it's not the
same
when i left l.a i said my goodbye to the
comedy store and i think i said my
goodbye
to the whole that whole [__] world i
hope not
i hope not i hope in three months i'm on
stage [__] around having a good time
locally at uncle vinnie's or something
but that's how i feel george and i miss
you guys
i miss you too dog my realm of comedy is
gone that was it
that's it it's time to go home yeah you
know you pick up your toys
and your ball and go home yeah you know
i i've hung out a couple times
it's still there dawg there's spurts of
it like you know what i mean
the but i just feel like
you rogan and red man came and
revolutionized it when they [__]
fired tommy
it was it'll never be like that again
but it's it's still there dog it's still
there
you know it's like the raiders dog we're
trying to make it look like how it was
in the 80s
the raiders in the 80s untouchable it's
going to be tough with a gay raider
what i ain't got nothing against gay
people but how the [__] is there a gay
raider
that coach the old coach must be [__]
spinning in his grave
al davis and all those dudes are like
how the [__] is there a gay raider
how do where do we go from here i can
see a gay 49er
a gay giant but a gay raider
and i got nothing against gay people you
know i'm part of the lgbt community i
love you got [__] to death
but there's no way on this earth that i
ever think there would be a gay raider
when that dude came out of the closet
and i saw the raiders shirt on them i'm
like this ain't right this is part of
god's joke with kovit
how is there a [__] gay raider
we got any dates coming up george yes
august
21st i'm at the continental room in
fullerton
september 8th american comedy club
san diego september 4th
novo theater in l.a shit's cr i'm on
that fool's gone wild you know what i
mean
it's a bomb ass new website they always
throw you up dog you gotta check out
fool's gone wild joey
i'll check them out today send them my
love for show brother i give you a
man like i didn't even feel like we
parked i don't want to hang up
you gotta go to work tonight huh you
gotta go to work
i gotta work tonight man hey dawg i feel
old when i'm at the strip club dog
i'm ready to let that [__] go it's
[__] with me
but everybody that works with me is
older than me that's the crazy part
[__] is [__] you know you can't touch
it but you can look at it till you're
90. you know what i'm saying
i mean i haven't hit nobody in 20 years
because i don't want to show enough for
you know you don't want to nobody wants
to see a 40 year old dick
you know what i'm saying after you four
when i became 40 i'm like that's it
my slinging dick days are over i better
find the girlfriend and i did i found
the wife and you know i found the wife
at 37 but at 40 i go i'm off
if we break up i'm done nobody wants to
see a 40 year old dick
and a 58 year old dick nobody i don't
even want to see it when i look at it i
go i can't believe it's my dick
that's the it was ugly to start with now
it looks like a [__] art bark i don't
even know what the [__] to do with it
i got a rash i got to put [__] petri
all around my dick
my legs what the [__] is going on with
this dog
i don't know getting there man i'm
working out again
little slow steps and [__] i'm on my
seventh day today
i'm gonna work out in like an hour feels
good dawg
it's the fountain of youth brother when
you're a man and you're getting older
weights
is to found the youth anything else will
get hurt jiu jitsu i'll get hurt kick
boxing i'll get hurt
you know i hit the bag still one day a
week twice a week but
the [__] gym is my bread and butter
george it's
uh it's really helped me to get to here
so
you look good homie i'm trying brother
you know like i told you the other night
no
weed till night time no edibles in the
daytime
you know because whenever i'm with you
you always be like where's it at where's
where the where's it at and you [__]
believe that bro so that's why i'm
saying
that wasn't like a change i implemented
or never you know i never even dreamed
of quitting smoking pot
i never even thought about it that was
never even a [__] thought to me
like when those guys that do so brocktob
i go go [__] yourself i'm gonna be
[__] sober
i got sober on my own because my body
didn't need it no more
yeah your body i've been there i think
that whole game
had me all [__] up and uh i feel
better now
behind this [__] powerful dog dog i
was getting anxiety they put a [__]
heart monitor on me i got no anxiety now
you know what i'm saying when i test my
blood pressure here i'm always high i go
to the doctor
i'm right on when you scare me with the
doctor everything goes away you tell me
you give me a needle everything goes
away
i went for a blood test i when i left
the blood test i felt a lot [__]
better
but i'm gonna keep doing what i'm doing
you keep doing what i'm what you're
doing
and we'll meet in the [__]
middle i love you with all my heart
i miss you and i wish you nothing but
success
in about two weeks i'll zoom in to your
podcast
[__] yeah man i appreciate that brother
all right brother
i love you i didn't forget about you
i'll never forget about you one of my
closest friends you always had my back
we did great together on the road we
were [__] up audiences together
so i wish you nothing but love good
health and i'll see you sooner than
later dog
all right make sure to tell tripley to
book you here and
i'll come see you oh yeah you know what
uh they've been hitting me up out there
i'm gonna go out there man
hey i had a dream dog that i had real
quick i had a dream last night
that i flew out there and you were all
mad at me when i show up i always you be
like what the [__] you doing george
supposed to call me if you're going to
come i want to [__]
make it it was funny doug listen if
somebody else don't call i get pissed at
them you don't need the call
you just show up at newark you call from
newark and say get the bong ready
i'll put it in the freezer and we'll get
that freeze pipe and start smoking that
[__] i love you dog
stay black and keep in touch we always
talk twice a week so
i love you brother stay black loving
your dog late
late all right i hope you enjoyed that
little [__] tata tay
with george perez uh it was a hell of a
podcast it brought back a lot of
memories
i worked hard guys and that was i wanted
to prove to you [__] guys that
l.a was no uh fluke
we [__] killed it i used to have
spots at the store every night
following mooney but before i used to do
that
i would go out and do other spots i
would do open mics i would do paid gigs
it's all a gig you got to get on stage
and
you know when i lived in boulder my
motto was get on stage once a night when
i moved to seattle
it was twice a night when i moved to l.a
my goal was
40 spots a [__] month but i would
take 30. you know what i'm saying like
if i did 30
30 times 12 is 360 spots a [__] year
i used to average somewhere in the 400s
every year so it's 400
spots a year that's a spot every day and
a half a [__] spot when you had it up
so
if you're thinking about starting to do
comedy that's the [__] way to do it
a spot a night and then you graduate to
two spots a night
then you graduate to three spots tonight
and then get back to me i'll tell you
what your mission is then
i love you [__] with all my
heart thank you for supporting the
[__] uh
joint this week and uh i'm happy you
enjoyed it
i hope you have a great weekend and
we'll be back monday
tip top magoo with uncle joey's [__]
joint have a great weekend
and now for a word for my [__]
sponsors jack
all right i want to thank my man george
perez i want to thank you guys for
watching and you guys for the support
but before i get the [__] out of here i
want to thank my sponsors for the week
cbd lion coming at you again on a
beautiful [__] wednesday in august
how does cbd lion gonna help you simple
go to cbdlion.com right now
read read the third-party lab results
they've done all the work for you
whether you get the roll-on the cream
the capsules the hemp weed
they even got a vapor pen for you no
matter how you could ingest a cbd
lion has got you covered the gummy bears
[__] tremendous [__] tremendous
carried me during the [__] surgery
the surgical tape i mean listen
if you need cbd help cbd line you don't
know where to get started nobody knows
where to start
cbd line is where to start read
read read the third party lab results
read the elements read the cures cbd
line will take you out of [__] your
funk with a bad elbow whatever the [__]
it is anxiety
cbd line is here to [__] help you go
to cbd lion
read see how they can help you in order
once you order you're going to be so
[__] happy
with the product you're going to call me
back and say joey what the [__] is in
there
even my brother came down last night and
asked me for some gummies
that's how good cbd lion is so right now
on the way out of your order and to joey
joint church and get 20 off your
[__] order
right now at cbd lion and also from the
heart of new jersey
the joint is brought to you by
[__] draftkings
they're doing it again a hundred to one
odds if a punch lands
during the main fight of lewis versus
gain the heavyweight
[__] interim title draftkings has a
kick-ass offer for you
again a hundred to one odds a single
[__] punch
are you [__] crazy or what you better
dollar on any main event fighter
and if a punch lands during the fight
you will cash
100 and free [__] credits that's four
more [__] baseball games or whatever
the [__] at 25 hours
they're [__] putting a yardstick in
your pocket for a dollar
if you know anything about mma then you
got to put your money where your mouth
is
either way you're getting paid this
weekend a [__] punch
are you [__] serious only draftkings
would do that
mma isn't you okay draftkings has great
odds on baseball and
the [__] tokyo games and a sports
betting casino
which will make your [__] pubic hairs
curl up
your little ass hairs or [__] blow a
[__] load draftkings are safe
secure and reliable you withdraw your
money at your
[__] convenience you understand me
draftkings ain't here to tell you what
to do
don't miss out on all the action on ufc
265 with draftkings this weekend
the top-rated sportsbook app in the
[__] country
and the partner to the ufc download the
draftking sportsbook app now right now
use promo code joey when you sign up to
turn
one dollar into a hundred dollars in
free credits
when you bet any main event fighter to
win
and a punch has landed in the either
fight who's better than draftkings
nobody you got to use code joey to turn
one dollar into 100 and free thr
credits only at draftking sportsbook
here's the fine print you ready
you got to be 21 older new jersey
indiana
pennsylvania only new customers only for
this deal
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details also download the
sportsbook not the fantasy for this one
fantasy is a complete different game
only at draftkings sportsbook
see draftkingsportsbook.com for details
got a gaming problem
called 1-800 gambler or in indiana 1 809
with it now if you don't have any
problems and you're [__] straight
download the draftking sportsbook app
today and win some [__] getus this
weekend
i want to thank draftkings i want to
thank cbd lion
i want to thank zip recruiter and blue
chew for having our back this week
but most importantly i want to thank you
[__] savages
for the love and support i love your
[__] and don't forget
laughing gas is still available it's
still [__] people
up and it's [__] tremendous i'm
patting myself on the back
like i said during the podcast stay
black have a great weekend and i'll see
you monday
tip top [__] magoo
who's better than you nobody
you